you know in terms of core conjuring
movies
now the conjuring trilogy with the
conjuring the devil made me do it
two out of three ain't bad
[Music]
so the conjuring the devil made me do it
is actually it's the conjuring three
that there are a lot of movies in the
conjuring universe a lot of spin-offs
and though the conjuring devil made me
do it sounds like a conjuring spin-off
and feels like one it's actually the
country three so once again in the
conjuring there's this family that's
being tormented by this demon
and a witch that cursed the family and
now the warrens have to stop it or
at the very least go in a boring
investigative romp while they play
magnum pi
what i liked about this movie is some of
the witch stuff was
kind of cool that's that's not good when
you have someone reviewing a movie like
this
and they're really scraping to find
something they like and they're like
well the witch thing was kind of neat
like that scene in the trailer
was like oh it's my wife i'll fooled you
yeah well the movie's not that great
then
as simple as that actually the movie
starts out pretty sweet it starts out on
a pretty high note because that exorcism
scene at the beginning
was actually pretty entertaining and
it's just kind of all downhill from
there man i'm really bagging on this one
you know the bummer is this movie is
confused not confusing but confused it
doesn't really know what it wants to be
i mean you watch the trailer you're like
oh it's like a courtroom drama slash
haunting movie slash possession movies
like the conjurings taking on
the exorcism of emily rose all right
sweet that could be interesting
the whole courtroom thing is such a
small part of it it's just the setup and
it's it's the setup
to get the warrens out there
investigating don't look for it being
like oh a compelling court case
movie with haunting stuff it's not
i'll bring it up because the trailer
definitely made it look like it was
gonna be this movie has identity crisis
changing up the formula
in the third movie it's nothing new buy
a third movie or a third season
you usually see some sort of formula
shake-up that said that shake-up doesn't
work in this movie because all right you
look at the conjuring one and two you
have a house you have a family
you have a demon you have a haunting
it's a closed quarters setting where
every dingy dark hallway
sends your fight or flight reflexes on
high alert every open door
leading to a dimly lit room tells every
fiber in your body
stay the [ __ ] away a haunted house movie
is a good way of having the scares
not stop when the end credits roll the
audience takes it home with them because
they go too that's right a house
the conjuring the devil made me do it
has the warrens going out there
investigating this thing going to this
location going to this location
following the breadcrumbs following the
trail to hopefully find this person
who's cursed his family which could work
i have seen myself many a supernatural
investigative movie
fallen being among the most underrated
of them but this movie
it just didn't work i just found it
boring there was nothing scary that was
going on it's like the movie gave you
effects i've seen in the trailers like
oh this effect happened
how cool is that but it's not scary it's
just it's an effect that happened to
remind
you that there's still something going
on with this family yeah you'll have a
face of a demon or a ghost in a water
bed making the demon or ghost the second
most
unsettling thing in the room second only
to the waterbed and even the demon when
possessing someone
isn't scary it's just like all the demon
does is just bend and twist and scream
which sounds like what demons do but
that's like
the defining characteristic of this
demon belial lord of lies
and that one lord of contortion
you really drew the short stick on that
one didn't you
[ __ ] i mean in a lot of haunted house
and or possession movies there's
usually an investigative element in
there there's usually a truth to uncover
a root cause
to get to the bottom of but it usually
serves to enhance the experience the
movie's still there
to scare the [ __ ] out of you any scare
moments that are in this movie feel like
they're there for
support for the main point which is the
investigation problem
is the investigation is just not that
interesting in the end the conjuring the
devil made me do it
feels like the type of conjuring
spin-off the title makes it sound like
it actually is
i wasn't invested i wasn't interested
there weren't a lot of scares there were
a couple of interesting and
if not cool things but in the end this
movie's gonna fall into the bin of the
forgotten
i'm just not gonna remember the
conjuring the devil made me do it in
t-minus one day
yeah already forgot all right so the
conjuring the devil made me do it have
you seen it
what did you think about it you're not
gonna see it what you're waiting you
have your
15 bucks for your ticket your movie
ticket you're like i'm going back to the
movie theater they're opening up this is
the movie i'm gonna watch
that's not the case let's not lie to
ourselves but in the off chance you have
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you